[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy nos
acompaña el doctor carlos eduardo pérez
asesor científico de france 24 y médico
infectólogo de la universidad nacional
de colombia autor o buen día gracias por
estar aquí con nosotros en france 24 la
agencia de medicamentos de eeuu la de
fedea aprobó la eficacia de la vacuna de
johnson and johnson sería la tercera
vacuna contra el kobe 19 aprobada en
eeuu con la particularidad de tener un
66% global de eficacia le pregunto a
doctor qué significa un 66% y qué opina
de los análisis publicados sobre esta
vacuna
son buenas noticias el hecho que sea 66%
es una protección global pero evita el
coit severo y el código moderado y
también se mostró que ninguno de los
pacientes vacunados falleció por kobe es
una muy buena noticia porque es una
vacuna segura además de eso se por se
probó su eficacia en poblaciones mayores
de edad es una sola dosis y no requiere
una cadena de frío exigente
definitivamente es una muy buena opción
y un nuevo elemento que tenemos para
poder vacunar a nuestra población ahora
doctor en europa la vacuna astrazéneca
ha tenido inconvenientes en el
cumplimiento del plazo de entrega y un
estudio oficial alemán señaló evidencias
de efectos secundarios son más graves
que sus dos principales rivales como
analiza la vacuna astrazéneca que tanto
le puede afectar una opinión
desfavorable de altos funcionarios
europeos
este tipo de vacunas están sometidas
ahora a grandes ensayos que es la
demostración de su actividad en tiempo
real en la vida real y se van a
encontrar algún tipo de estudios que
muestran si actúa bien si no actúa así
lo que se vio en los estudios es una
realidad y lo mismo con las reacciones
adversas hasta ahora la información hay
que recibirla con cautela sigue siendo
una vacuna segura y hay también opciones
de hacer modificaciones en la
dosificación a cada tres meses que han
demostrado una eficacia sostenida por
ahora la información con cautela y hay
que vacunarse si tenemos la opción con
este tipo de vacuna eeuu y varios países
de américa latina están experimentando
en febrero un descenso en los contagios
porque hoy 19 el doctor a qué se debe
le pregunto si la vacunación oa la
inmunidad de rebaño
por ahora es muy pronto para hablar de
la unidad de rebaño definitivamente hay
dos cosas una que el aumento de los
picos hace que mayor tipo de personas no
sean susceptibles unas porque se
recuperaron otras porque tuvieron
acogida sintomático y tienen defensas
claro que también impacta firmemente la
vacunación para disminuir el número de
casos y que hemos aprendido en este
tiempo un comportamiento social del
alejamiento eso explica la disminución
de casos no quiere que sean eliminado
pero hasta que no aseguremos una
vacunación más viva y eficaz a más del
70% de la población no podemos hablar de
inmunidad de rebaño cuba doctor es el
único país de américa latina en fabricar
su propia vacuna y ya tenía varios de
sus prototipos en fase 3 le pregunto con
malú cómo evalúa el proceso cubano de
estas vacunas y además si es confiable
el hecho de realizar las vacunas por un
propio país me parece que es un hecho
destacable sin embargo estas
informaciones hay que recibirlas con
cautela porque hasta ahora tenemos
informaciones oficiales pero no estudios
científicos no datos verificados por
padres y no publicaciones en donde
podamos analizar los datos sin embargo
cuál tiene una tradición de producir
vacunas y es necesario esperar el
publiquen sus resultados que nos
muestren qué tipo de vacunas son y
probablemente tengamos también una
opción más en un futuro y ante la
competitividad de laboratorios y
farmacéuticas la comunidad científica
internacional trabaja actualmente en lo
que se llama una vacuna universal contra
la pandemia le pregunto doctor entonces
de qué se trata
el desarrollo de nuevas vacunas va a
tener dos frentes adicionales uno nuevas
vacunas para las cepas o linajes virales
distintos y también una vacuna universal
qué significa eso que con una sola
vacuna se puede hacer a todos los
linajes de coronavirus ser efectiva ese
es el que se apuesta a futuro en el
momento para la vacunación masiva y
seguramente ese será el final de esta
pandemia si lo logramos que así sea
doctor muchísimas gracias como siempre
por su tiempo por estar aquí con
nosotros en france 24 al doctor carlos
obando pérez asesor científico de
nuestro canal y médico infectólogo de la
universidad nacional de colombia hasta
aquí cinco minutos continuo con nosotros
[Música]